FRANK: We're in the heart
of gas and oil.
We're heading to meet
Mr. More and his son Mike.
The family ran a service
station from the early 1900s.
They closed in the '90s,
and supposedly
they kept everything.
MIKE: Look at this place!
FRANK: Wow, this is cool.
Grab the flyer.
MIKE: Ah... Frankie!
FRANK: This place is cool, man.
MIKE: Oh my gosh,
are you kiddin' me?
MIKE: Hello!
FRANK: Hello.
FRANK: Whoa...
CARL: Mike!
FRANK: Got some
square footage up here.
MIKE: No way.
FRANK: Mr. More, Frank.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
MIKE MORE: Pleasure to meet you.
FRANK: Nice to meet you, sir.
MIKE: Mike, nice to meet you.
Hello, how are you?
Good to meet you guys.
MIKE: I gotta say,
the curb appeal of
this building is incredible.
MR. MORE: It was a very
busy gas station.
We're midway between Dallas
and Lubbock and Amarillo.
MIKE: Yeah.
MR. MORE: So this was
the main route of traffic,
and they all
came by this station,
because there
was no freeway.
FRANK: Oh.
MIKE: This place was like
an oasis for the weary traveler.
MR. MORE: They were open 7
days a week, 24 hours a day.
MIKE: Wow!
So what did you guys use
this space for up here, then?
MR. MORE: They had an ordinance
back in the '30s and early '40s
against parking
overnight on the street.
MIKE: Really?
MR. MORE: So if people
stayed in the hotel,
you would come over here
and park your car
and we got 40 or 50
cents a night.
MIKE: No way!
FRANK: Way to go.
MIKE: Cars would pull up
right here, huh?
MIKE MORE: Yeah.
MR. MORE: Yes, uh-huh.
MIKE: Look how narrow
that is, Frank.
MR. MORE: This ramp
was made for Model Ts.
MIKE: Oh, okay, okay.
MIKE: Can we look
over here first?
MIKE: This is like walking
through a petroliana
history museum.
MIKE: So was this stuff left
over from the storage business?
MIKE MORE: A lot of this
I acquired.
A few of them are family pieces
that we put up here,
you know, uh...
MIKE: Where'd that
come out of?
MIKE MORE: As far as I know,
it was probably
in the oil refinery offices
that would have been back here.
MIKE: Oh, this was
office space up here?
MIKE MORE: This originally was.
It later became the VFW.
I've heard stories that--
a guy that got drunk
and drove his motorcycle
up these back stairs...
MIKE: Uh-huh...
[laughs]
MIKE MORE: And didn't
figure out how to get it down.
So they had to bust a hole in
the wall and take it down
the ramp for the cars...
MIKE: Oh my gosh.
MIKE MORE: ...through there.
FRANK: It's cool seeing
a young guy like Mike
being so passionate about
his family's history.
MIKE MORE: I feel a sense
of pride being able to carry
the family history on.
I take a lot of pride in that.
MIKE: Hey, thanks for sharing
your family's history with us.
FRANK: Thank you so much.
MIKE: Good luck with the museum.
MIKE MORE: Thank you.
FRANK: You bet.
MIKE: Alright, we appreciate it.
You come to Nashville,
you'll see that.
CARL: Be safe.
FRANK: Alright guys.
Take care.
MIKE: God bless you guys.
[honks horn]
FRANK: Later, guys!
Take care!
MIKE MORE: Later.